when you think of the Miami Dolphins a
few names first come to mind like Tyreek
Tua and Jaylen wad but the real unsung
hero of the Dolphins high-scoring
offense has been their running game
specifically Raheem moer and if you
don't believe me here are three stats to
back that up moer is currently leading
the NFL with 11 total touchdowns through
six games those 11 touchdowns are more
than all of these teams having more
touchdowns than entire teams is crazy
but what's even crazyer is that moer has
more touchdowns than all of these
running backs combined and don't forget
the other Dolphins running back Devon
aain had seven of his own touchdowns
which means most's totals could have
been even higher and now with Devon aain
recovering from injury it's safe to say
that Raheem Mard is going to have an
even bigger role and continue to help
the Dolphins run over the NFL this
season